que wayne minaar longue journaliste
consultant bonsoir oui mme hemming merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
a en compte quel est l'état d'esprit qui
prédomine aujourd'hui la colère la peur
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de très
spontané après donc sachant que dia
l'oeil à la pandémie qui s'est mêlée
tout ça que ça s'était arrêté pendant
quelques mois je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de spontané et de beaucoup moins
organisé qu'il pouvait y avoir
auparavant
donc là tous les mouvements qu'on a vu
ces derniers jours sont des sondés
mouvement plutôt paisible et spontané
qui se déroule de manière on va dire
assez disparate nous ont organisé
beaucoup moins soumis à beaucoup moins
d' influence qu'auparavant extérieur
donc l'état d'esprit est vraiment dans
l'expectative et puis surtout dans la
avec beaucoup de surprise également
parce que comment dire jusque-là pékin
s'était montré extrêmement comment dire
a montré beaucoup de mansuétude envers
le mouvement démocratique de hong kong
est aujourd'hui on voit qui durcit le
ton que on était surpris même que pékin
ne le fasse pas plus tôt là aujourd'hui
on voit un vrai une véritable volonté de
changement de stratégie et surtout
d'avoir la mainmise sur ces mouvements
le hong kong et les six possibles les
pertes heures et justement pour quelle
raison comment vous vous l'expliquer qui
est moins peut-être de tolérance
désormais ce changement de stratégie
je ne m'explique pas tant ce cette
moindre tolérance que cette comme je
vous l ai dit cette grand-messe étude
qui était observé auparavant par rapport
à ces manifestations c'est à dire que
quand même par rapport aux nombres de
d'événements de manifestation qui a eu
avant là avant la pandémie
il ya eu très peu de victimes les aînés
la police cet homme a été très moment
délicate on va dire qu'on va avoir une
testant même s'il ya eu des débordements
mais bon il y avait tellement de
factions en actions à ce moment là qu'il
est et qu'il aurait été difficile de
démêler qui fait quoi là aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui vaut
davantage réfléchi et surtout
politiquement parce que ces annonces la
ne vienne bientôt moment où on qu'on va
bientôt certainement dans les jours qui
viennent
rouvrir les boîtes de nuit les bars et
chose ce genre de lieu mais aussi mettre
fin par exemple à la quarantaine pour
les gens qui arrivent à hong kong
donc en même temps qu'on va rouvrir
lille on va serrer la vis en quelque
sorte à ses habitants et sachant que
aussi que le la date de vote de cette
loi sur le référendum sur le seul hymne
national sur l'ut raja lim a été choisie
de manière et front stratégique puisque
il aura lieu le 4 juin soit la date
anniversaire de tiananmen ce qui veut
dire que les gens ne pourrons pas
manifester ce jour-là justement
qu'est-ce que ça dit parce que c'est pas
anodin vous l'avez dit outrage voilà
aline ça dit quoi justement ça dit enfin
évidemment on joue sur les symboles il
faut bien tenir compte de la culture
locale là on va se servir d'un symbole
pour exprimer toute une batterie de
mesures qui est effectivement seront
davantage répressive
c'est à dire que on a on a vu un avant
avant l'épidémie il y avait de la de
l'outragé au drapeau il y avait la lys
et création de pendant la profanation de
drapeaux par lens est un anglicisme
il y avait beaucoup de gestes dans ce
sens-là des drapeaux chinois brûlé des
drapeaux américains ben dis donc tous
les symboles qui pourrait être contre
qui pourrait aller à l'encontre de pékin
pourrait être davantage maîtrisée donald
trump lui est intervenu il promet une
réponse d'ici la fin de la semaine et
évoque une réaction très puissante
comment interpréter ces propos du du
président américain et que doit-on
attendre
on peut en attendre pas beaucoup de bien
malheureusement parce que on compte
jouit d'un statut particulier
donc par rapport aux commerces notamment
donc étant que selon les traités 1997
tant que c'est tant que une certaine
autonomie de dole il est respecté par
pékin et bien on compte du cdh un statut
particulier pour le commerce
international
donc ce qui se passe c'est que dans
donald trump pourrait remettre en
question ce traité et l'assimiler à la
chine je sais ce qui serait bien ce
serait extrêmement dommageable
évidemment or les hongkongais et c'est
un peu ça le problème c'est que sont les
hong kong et qui vont s'offrir donc
tâche que pékin ait un gosse mais allons
comme si c'est minuscule par rapport à
part à la chine mais le collatéral aussi
c'est que la balance commerciale entre
les états unis et hong kong est plutôt
très en faveur des états unis donc le
commerce américain en souffrir également
très justement mac pompéo a déjà annoncé
un petit peu là la couleur aujourd'hui
un selon lui on comble juil aps une
louve ne jouit plus de l'autonomie
promise vis-à-vis de pékin et donc ne
peut par conséquent continuer à
bénéficier de privilèges commerciaux
avec les états unis comment on
interprète ses propos chez vous
là je ne pouvais pas parler pour tout le
monde mais je suis activités de paris je
suis à l'écouté de ce qui se passe en
vous êtes banques ont des chinois de
hong kong votre famille
vie là bas on connaissait voilà comment
la situation mais n'étant pas sur place
le jour j ce à dire que c'est allé très
vite incertaine et jours tout s'est
passé en à peu près en même temps je ne
sais pas vraiment comment les gens
réagissent là bas je pense qu'il ya
certaines attentisme il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens regardent quand même
les états unis parce qu'il ya de
l'espoir
derrière il ya ce mouvement démocratique
qu'on loue ou pas on est d'accord ou pas
mais on sait que ils attendent beaucoup
des forces occidentales de faire quelque
chose pour les aider à accéder à une
chose parce qu'en fait tout les autres
revendications disparu aujourd'hui
au départ c'était l'extradition mobile
et après il ya plein de choses qui sont
arrivées aujourd'hui c'est devenu
beaucoup plus clair aussi bien du côté
de pékin que du côté de rencontre c'est
que les gens veulent l'indépendance de
roncq on est forcément ça ne plaît pas à
pékin
merci vous voyez un minya longue d'avoir
été avec nos journalistes consultants
hong kong et un chinois de hong kong
comme ça vous vous présentez vous étiez
en direct effectivement de paris merci à
vous